il faut que je people chers amis Beyoncé
la tournée de tous les records je pense
que vous n'avez pas pu passer à côté le
week-end dernier Beyoncé était à Paris
elle a donné un concert au Stade de
France un concert complètement démesuré
surtout une tournée démesurée regardez
et on en parle juste après c'était tout
de même magnifique c'est incroyable
[Musique]
c'était le concert le plus attendu de
l'année vendredi dernier Beyoncé a
enflammé le Stade de France devant des
dizaines de milliers de fans
[Applaudissements]
pendant presque trois heures et pour son
premier concert solo en France depuis 7
ans Queen Bee a délivré un show
magistral en enchaînant ses tubes dans
une ambiance survoltée
costume extravagants et sexy
chorégraphie et scénographie millimétré
la super star américaine c'est une
nouvelle fois montrée à la hauteur de sa
réputation de bête de scène ses fans qui
venaient parfois de très loin et qui ont
dû attendre très longtemps en ont eu
pour leur argent au tout début quand
elle a commencé à chanter les premiers
mots moi j'ai pleuré mais vraiment j'ai
pleuré sur scène la nouvelle reine du
Stade de France et même permise de
partager quelques pas de danse avec sa
fille de 11 ans Blue Ivy
sa tournée intitulé The Renaissance tour
ferait une nouvelle escale en France ce
sera le 11 juin prochain à Marseille au
stade Vélodrome mais ne cherchez pas à
acheter des billets les 115000 qui
avaient été mis en vente ce sont par
hachés en seulement 45 minutes en
février dernier
c'est aussi ça l'effet mignon c'est
[Applaudissements]
à vous j'adore j'adore j'adore Beyoncé
je suis pas allé moi j'ai un peu la
flemme du Stade de France
vous aviez juste à allumer votre
Instagram ce qui est un peu malheureux
là-dedans c'est que c'était
exceptionnelle mais sauf que ceux qui
vont aller à Marseille ils ont déjà tout
vu moi je le connais par cœur
un petit peu loin alors parce qu'on m'a
raconté moi j'ai pas d'argent je prépare
mon mariage donc je pouvais pas y aller
mais par contre j'ai regardé toutes les
images qu'on proposait et tout le monde
était un peu loin en fait c'était très
compliqué d'être très propre c'est
normal la scène définition
exceptionnelle sur les écrans donc
c'était on la voyait très très bien mais
c'est vrai que pour le coup moi perso
j'ai vu tous les tableaux je me suis
régalé et je pourrais faire comme si je
l'avais vu moi j'irai voir Mylène Farmer
et ça aussi
on a aussi le droit de détester le Stade
de France moi j'étais je devais y aller
avec un ami et moi c'est le Stade de
France et un artiste qu'on voit comme ça
au milieu j'aime pas du tout et puis je
trouve qu'il y a un aspect mécanique
quand même moi oh non c'est magnifique
c'est un gros travail d'ailleurs toutes
les répétitions ont eu lieu à Paris vous
savez qu'elle est resté trois mois à
Paris où elle a répété à lui Arena elle
avait loué l'urena pendant 3 mois elle a
répété tous les jours là elle était là
tous les jours alors moi je voulais vous
dire tout de même on va en parler encore
bien sûr ça tournait Renaissance World
Tour a démarré le 10 mai dernier avec
une première date à Stockholm pour une
durée de 57 shows dans le monde entier
Suède Belgique Angleterre Espagne
de Beyoncé au Stade de France donc pas
celui-ci mais celui-là qui était
incroyable c'est à dire que j'étais dans
la fosse car les vrais fans sont dans la
fosse j'ai été dans la fosse j'ai
attendais depuis 8h10 bar comme ça avec
mon avec non mais vraiment avec mon
petit gobelet en train d'attendre Queen
Bee le concert était exceptionnel j'ai
dansé avec des gens que je connaissais
même pas j'ai peu j'ai pleuré toutes les
larmes de mon corps bien évidemment je
l'ai vu elle s'approchaînement la scène
elle s'avancer comme ça et un moment
elle a failli frôler la 7 mains là elle
s'approche
et elle t'a dit salut Débo des jours
c'est la seule reine qui nous reste je
trouve de cette génération là c'est la
seule qui est sûr de vous
par rapport au prix où les gens ont payé
s'il y avait des prix à 70 et à 120 €,
je crois que aux toilettes
à 100 euros
regardez il faut savoir que selon le
magazine Forbes cette tournée de Beyoncé
pourrait être la plus lucrative de toute
histoire de la musique le site américain
annonce une recette totale de 2,1
milliard de dollars à la fin de la
tournée elle peut s'arrêter après les
enfants
récemment c'est Elton John qui a battu
un record avec sa tournée d'adieu fawell
yellow brick Road d'ailleurs il repasse
là bientôt à la corarena 800 millions de
dollars récoltés au bout de 300 dates
remarqué bosse le mec c'est du boulot on
les adore elle aurait même pu s'arrêter
avant de toute façon
génial elle le fait parce qu'elle adore
le chaud elle le fait
de malade
etc
aussi pareil Selena Gomez Pharrell
Williams Natalie Portman enfin voilà
tout le monde
préféré des stars
ouais et qu'elle accepte de de faire des
duos c'est par exemple quand tu es une
star sur scène d'ailleurs récemment on a
vu les images avec Tina Turner elle a
rendu hommage a-t-il un teneur
d'ailleurs au début du spectacle c'est
formidable c'est une fille sympa qui en
plus elle va gratuitement chanter avec
d'autres attendez je voudrais vous
donner les prix qu'est-ce que tu as
Francesca parce que non je croyais que
vous voulez aller aux toilettes vu le
oui aussi non non mais j'irai après non
mais 32 Gremi Awards quand même après
vous dites elle est sympa et elle veut
chanter avec tout le monde alors moi
encore une qui est venu à la Star
Academy qui n'a pas chanter avec moi non
mais c'est pas parce qu'elle a pas
chanter avec toi qu'elle est pas sympa
qu'elle voulait chanter avec tout le
monde elle aurait pu me faire de donuts
comme ça pour me faire quelque chose
du coup je suis allé la voir je lui ai
dit Beyoncé Beyoncé elle a fini par se
retourner et elle a regardé ma veste et
elle a dit chat vous voyez la marque en
taille et en mail et elle m'a dit non
j'ai dit non elle s'est barrée j'ai dit
mais reviens
[Applaudissements]
te signale que déjà Tina Turner tu as
fait le même coup alors tu as un
problème mon fils Enzo beaucoup plus
sympa
ils sont pardon mais ils sont très
sympathiques le temps où ils sont face à
vous ils sont super rodés très pro c'est
pas du tout une critique
avec moi alors est-ce que vous savez
est-ce que vous savez que les Américains
justement sont venus en nombre la voir
en France et vous savez pourquoi parce
que c'était moins cher les places sont
moins chères le billet d'avion plus la
place moi ouais ouais et justement alors
les recettes exceptionnelles de la
chanteuse la tournée majoritairement
gérée par sa propre compagnie ça vous le
savez tout comme la
merchandising alors vous savez c'est les
t-shirts les affiches les sweats les
casquettes et ça c'est fou d'où lui
revient c'est elle à 100%. elle prend
80% des des recettes sur le
marchandising vous achetez un pull en
général je crois qu'ils sont aux
alentours de 100 et quelques euros quand
vous achetez au concert elle touche 80%
sur ses 100 euros là
qui vont bénéficier de ça parce que je
sais pas vous mais moi quand j'ai vu
comme Francesca sur Instagram toutes les
vidéos le lendemain je suis allée sur
mon ordinateur et j'ai pris plein de
places de concerts pour Sting Bigflo et
Oli ça ça m'a donné envie
il y a les fait pas Sting et d'autres
concerts c'est l'ambiance des concerts
et je pense qu'il y a plein d'artistes
qui vont bénéficier de la venue
alors c'est pas faux vous savez combien
il était le prix des billets au fait au
Stade de France 700 euros 839 838
une place à côté d'elle sur la scène
déjà à faire un petit calcul je crois
que sur le sur la recette elle est à peu
près à 10 millions elle doit se faire au
moins 3 millions de bénéfices pour elle
contrôle
à 3 millions voilà ça vous donne un peu
la marche bénéficiaire
à 37 millions
de dollars de rentrer financière globale
chaque soir
alors justement les produits dérivés ça
lui rapporterait 171 millions de dollars
et sur les quelques maladies Deborah 80%
pour elle in the pocket c'est énorme
c'est énorme mais on parle souvent de
Beyoncé comme la plus grande actrice
certaine la plus grande chanteuse et ça
c'est clair c'est la patronne mais aussi
la patronne du business quoi elle
survole le business mondial on se
souvient quand même qu'en 2015 elle a
fait un coup absolument génial elle est
allée chanter pour Hubert la marque de
VTC pour une soirée privée ils ont
proposé 6 millions de dollars pour le
cachet pour venir elle a dit vous savez
quoi vous ne donnez pas 6 millions de
dollars vous donnez des actions uber
quand c'est rentré en bourse elle a pris
300 millions de dollars
franchement
vous avez vu qu'en tout cas sur scène
elle a fait venir sa fille Blue Idy
adorable comme tout avec tous ses
danseurs etc vous savez que ça fait
déplacer aussi de très nombreuses stars
vous avez vu par exemple
en même temps alors Selena Gomez Kylie
Jenner
Williams aussi Kelly avait notre Kelly
[Musique]
il a manqué qu'une c'était Jean-Paul
Gaultier Olivier rousta puisqu'il
habillé évidemment
en tout cas bravo Beyoncé c'était un
grand plaisir moi je l'ai pas vu voilà
moi je vous dis ça de France je dirais
oui
c'est quand même cher mais on quand même
que celui au Stade de France c'était the
place to be parce que pour faire
déplacer toutes les stars américaines
qui l'ont apporté demain là-bas les mecs
se sont tous déplacés pour venir la voir
au Stade de France alors qu'ils habitent
pas du tout en France a priori c'était
la première c'était quand même un peu la
première de la tournée non c'est pour ça
j'ai dit tout à l'heure mais c'est pas
grave aux gens qui fait un peu pays 700
balles pour regarder le concert comme ça
sans regarder l'artiste sans garantie
chez toi
tu demandes aux gens ils diraient la
même chose mais quand je suis un endroit
je kiffe l'instant je suis pas en train
de filmer
un petit moment de filmer le mollet de
balancer pour montrer
le film certains concerts parce que ça
me fait plaisir de le partager sur
Instagram pour streamer pour dire j'y
étais quoi
c'est Bernard
que tu as par exemple je sais pas qui
j'ai vu la dernière fois mais tu
partages Indochine tu partages ton
plaisir de voir sur scène il y a des
gens qui peuvent pas y aller mais les
gens j'ai pas besoin de toi pour le voir
il m'accélération
de croire que ça leur fait plaisir
Jean-Michel moi c'est vrai que c'est
chiant de voir tous les gens filmer et
toi tu peux même pas regarder